we can identify three distinct layers of
learning let's start with the first
layer evolutionary learning continuously
try random things and keep doing what
works well it's a slow learning process
that happens over Generations the key
point is out of this evolutionary
learning process we see intelligence
emerge as hardwired Form and Function
where fixed behaviors are triggered by a
fixed sense this leads to the next layer
of learning we see grow out of the
evolutionary process in life learning
based on experience resulting in
Behavior which adapts within a lifetime
this layer of learning is what we use
our brains for allowing connections
between sense and action to evolve
within life a new kind of thought
emerges what we could call abstract
learning it allows us to imagine
situations we haven't experienced and
gauge what will happen so we can adapt
our Behavior accordingly